foreign
says you have to get ready to retire
financially
and of course you do
but what they don't tell you is that you
also have to get ready psychologically
who knew
but it's important for a couple of
reasons
first
10
000 North Americans will retire today
and every day for the next 10 to 15
years
this is a retirement tsunami
and when these folks come crashing onto
the beach a lot of them are going to
feel like fish out of water
without a clue as to what to expect
secondly it's important because there is
a very good chance that you will live
one third of your life in retirement
so it's important that you have a heads
up to the fact that there will be
significant psychological changes and
challenges that come with it
I belong to a walking group that meets
early three mornings a week
our primary goal is to put 10 000 steps
on our fitbits
and then we go for coffee and cinnamon
buns more important
[Applause]
so we've gotten the habit of as we walk
we've got in the habit of choosing a
topic for discussion
and one day the topic was how do you
squeeze all the juice out of retirement
how's that for seven o'clock in the
morning
so we walk and we talk and the next day
we go on to the next topic but the
question stayed with me because I was
really having some challenges with
retirement
I was busy enough but I really didn't
feel that I was doing very much that was
significant or important
I was really struggling
I thought I had a pretty good idea of
what success looked like in a working
career
but when it came to retirement it was
fuzzier for me
so I decided to dig deeper
and what I discovered was that much of
the material on retirement focuses on
the financial and or the estate side of
things and of course they're both
important but just not what I was
looking for
so I interviewed dozens and dozens of
retirees and I asked them the question
how do you squeeze all the juice out of
retirement
what I discovered was that there is a
framework that can help make sense of it
all and that's what I want to share with
you today
you see there are four distinct phases
that most of us move through in
retirement
and as you'll see it's not always a
smooth ride
in the next few minutes you'll recognize
which phase you're in if you're retired
and if you're not you'll have a better
idea of what to expect when that time
comes
and best of all you'll know that there
is a phase four the most gratifying
satisfying of the four phases and that's
where you can squeeze all the juice out
of retirement
phase one is the vacation phase and
that's just what it's like
you wake up when you want you do what
you want all day and the best part is
that there is no set routine
for most people phase one represents
their view of an ideal retirement
relaxing fun in the sun Freedom baby
and for most folks phase one lasts for
about a year or so
and then strangely it begins to lose its
luster
we begin to feel a bit bored
we actually miss our routine
something in US seems to need one
and we ask ourselves
is that all there is to retirement
now when these thoughts and feelings
start to Bubble Up
you have already moved into phase two
phase two is when we feel loss and we
feel lost
phase two is when we lose the big five
significant losses all associated with
retirement
we lose that routine
we lose a sense of identity
we lose many of the relationships that
we have had established at work
we lose a sense of purpose and for some
people there is a loss of power
now we don't see these things coming we
didn't see these losses coming and
because they happen all at once it's
like poof
gone
it's traumatic
phase two is also when we come face to
face with the three d's
divorce
depression and decline both physical and
mental
the result of all of this is that we can
feel like we've been hit by a bus
you see before we can appreciate and
enjoy some of the positive aspects
associated with with phase three and
four
you are going to in phase two feel fear
anxiety and quite even depression
that's just the way it is
so buckle up
get ready
fortunately at some point most of us say
to ourselves hey I can't go on like this
I don't want to spend the rest of my
life
perhaps 30 years feeling like this
and when we do we've turned a corner to
phase three
phase three is a time of trial and error
in phase three we ask ourselves how can
I make my life meaningful again
how can I contribute
the answer often is to do things that
you love to do
and do really well
but phase three can also deliver some
disappointment and failure
for example
I spent a couple of years serving on a
condo board
until I finally got tired of being
yelled at
yeah
you see one year the board decided that
we were going to plant daffodils rather
than the traditional daisies
and we got yelled at
go figure
I thought about law school thinking
perhaps of of becoming a paralegal and
then I completed a program on dispute
resolution
it all went nowhere
I love to write
so I created a program called getting
started on your memoirs
that program has met with limited
success
it's been a rocky road for me too and I
told you to buckle up
now I know all this can sound bad
but it's really important to keep trying
and experimenting with different
activities that'll make you want to get
up in the morning again
because if you don't there's a real good
chance of slipping back into phase two
feeling like you've been hit by a bus
and that is not a happy Prospect
not everyone breaks through to phase
four
but those who do are some of the
happiest people I have ever met
phase four is a time to reinvent and
rewire
but phase four involves answering some
tough questions too like what's what's
the purpose here what's my mission how
can I squeeze all the juice out of
retirement
you see it's important that we find
activities that are meaningful to us and
that give us a sense of accomplishment
and my experience is that it almost
always involves service to others
maybe it's helping a charity that you
care about
maybe you'll be like the old Coots yeah
these folks took a booth in the local
farmers market and were prepared to give
their advice based on their vast years
of experience
to anyone who came by
or maybe you'll be like my friend bill
I met Bill a few years ago in a 55 plus
activity group
in the summer we golfed together and
walked together and bicycle together and
in the winter we curl but Bill had this
idea that that we should exercise our
brains as well
he believed that there was a tremendous
pool of expertise and and experience in
our group and so he approached a number
of folks and asked if they would
volunteer to teach some of the things
that they love to do to others and
almost invariably they agreed
Bill himself taught two sessions one on
iPads and one on iPhones
because we were smart enough to know
that a number of our members had been
given these things as gifts at Christmas
by their children
and that they barely knew how to turn
them on right
the first year we offered nine programs
and there were 200 folks signed up
the next year that number expanded of 45
programs with over 700 folks
participating
and the following year we offered over
90 programs and had 2100 registrations
amazing amazing
that was that was Bill
our members taught us to play bridge and
meijong they taught us to paint they
taught us to repair our bicycles we
tutored and mentored local school kids
we set up English as a second language
programs for for newcomers we had book
clubs we had film clubs we even had a
few golf clubs exhausting but but
exhilarating
that's what's possible in phase four
and do you remember the five losses that
we talked about in phase two loss of our
routine and identity and relationships
and purpose and Power in phase four
these are all recovered it is Magic to
see Magic
so
I urge you
to enjoy your vacation in phase one
be prepared for the losses in phase two
experiment and try as many different
things as you can in phase three
and squeeze all the juice out of
retirement in phase four
[Applause]